I have not called President Xi  personally or President Putin personally  and the reason is because number one I  shouldn't have to this is something that  routinely is dealt with between law  enforcement officials in various  countries and this is not exceptional  from a legal perspective number two  we've got a whole lot of business that  we do with China and Russia and I'm not  going to have one case of a suspect who  were trying to extra extradite suddenly  being elevated to the point where I've  got to start doing wheeling and dealing  and trading on a whole host of other  issues simply to get a guy extradited so  that he can face the justice system here  in the United States not I get why is a  fascinating story from a press  perspective you know and I'm sure there  will be a made-for-tv movie somewhere  down the line